[Music]
in unfair treatment news oh damn
talk about my life I was gonna say that
but then I was like now I'm not gonna
say that submitted by a Sally and no
arms a teacher was handcuffed and
dragged from a school board meeting
after questioning a superintendent's pay
raise can't speak up at that school
how was he trying to speak up that was
he trying to like be all aggressive and
lie how dare this teacher [ __ ] ask
for a raise the nerve okay
superintendent intended whatever these
guys should be paid like nothing man
what the [ __ ] is wrong with them yes
give me fifty cents more [ __ ] this is a
pretty big story right now
yeah it's causing a lot of comments so
this happen teachers should be
millionaires by the way for real because
they teach the [ __ ] future yeah if
for all my past teachers they had to put
in a lot of work for having me in the
class you know they deserve way more do
some teachers just snap - yeah kid can't
take it anymore she just not not uh this
is one kidney man Tony on my class and
this change is started like pinching um
slapping them dragging them around like
he made him made her break and I was
like she didn't know no I don't even
think he complained yeah if the only
person I should have complained anyone
complain like he mooned her it all kind
of stuff
wow that's funny like I was a bad kid
and I and this is me Odie getting kicked
out of two schools but once I went to
once I got into this class I think I
actually didn't get in trouble at all
that whole year yeah because I had
someone else should I mean so the antics
that I were up to like sneaking my
friend's cat into class like it was
nothing so she just pinched him and like
dragging around in front of everyone no
one's that [ __ ] dragging I'm like
there's times where like she's got so
pissed
pulled him by the ear dragged on my saw
my elementary school is all connected
dragged them all the way
to the principal's office and all of us
are just sitting there like wait did our
teacher just leave the room oh wait this
is elementary school Oh back then people
weren't [ __ ] sue crazy oh yeah how
old are you guys a fourth grade so I was
like nine no whatever and then know the
kids spoke up probably they didn't know
yeah I think kids were I mean no one
really care about suing that much yeah
so this all takes place at a board
meeting they're forming people involved
it's Dasia the board president the
superintendent and the officer now deja
hartgrave
she is a middle school English teacher
in southern Louisiana she was formerly a
Teacher of the Year she was arrested and
booked into city jail overnight on the
charges oh yeah on the charges of
resisting an officer remaining after
being forbidden but she was later
released on bond this all happened
because there was in during this board
meeting they were talking about a
superintendent getting a pay raise and
so he was getting he was getting a raise
from a hundred and ten thousand dollars
to a hundred and forty eight hundred
superintendents make so much money in
the south they make hundred forty eight
thousand for superintendents make Bank
what yeah yeah and so well that's kind
of like being the school CEO or the
district yes people question it because
they don't really know what they do cuz
they approve like a curriculum and that
curriculum applies for like than for
5-10 years yeah yeah so what did the
superintendent doing now after that you
know so likely yeah it's very
questionable for a lot of people so he's
saying that he had not received a raise
since he took the job back in 2013
where's anyone that's why he's already
making a hundred ten grand yeah exactly
so in Louisiana this yeah what did he do
to deserve it like his performance was
great or like the board was saying that
he helped reach these goals but then
that's when this teacher she stood up
and she was like against it and I'm
gonna show you guys the clip from the
board meeting you guys okay so the
superintendent was getting this raise
and in this teacher was against it
because she didn't think he deserved
that she was pointing out the fact that
teachers in the area
they haven't gotten a raise in the past
ten years like why is he getting the
raise when they're the ones meeting the
numbers for who this is current so this
happened in 2017 or something this
happen this just happened so 2018 all
right whatever happened within the week
or two here yeah and there's just a huge
discrepancy like a hundred and ten or
140 grand in Louisiana and there's like
half a million dollars yeah and I mean
what do the teachers get 30,000 a year
47 to 48 yeah no that's that's too huge
of a pay wage yeah for them getting like
three grand is a big deal for them but
they went from fifty to fifty three
[Music]
video that that's really you know what
college president superintendent and
administrator Chancellor's like 800 yeah
I want to know what they do that get
them so much money and are is it a 24/7
job no because like CEOs and stuff I get
it it's a 24/7 job it's like why would
anyone want to do that job because you
don't have a life you don't have a wife
you don't you get divorced you're just
[ __ ] crazy
right but do these jobs are they as
demanding as like being a company CEO
for Apple for universities is different
it is it's the same thing like you have
like the sports side of it you have
entire medical complexes in your campus
like a lot of the universities they have
their own Police Department cuz it's
literally its own City and a really
compacted like square mile block type of
thing so it's like being a city mayor
plus CEO plus Pollak politician all this
stuff and in your city with its own like
high levels for City you are a president
yeah okay because these guys this is
like a [ __ ] junior high or something
and it's like what for what I almost
burped just before I show you guys the
video I just do want to make a little
side note here the officer involved in
this whole thing he was previously sued
for excessive force back in 2011 he's
back on the job he was accused of
slamming a 62 year old man's head into
concrete the lawsuit end up being
settled in 2016 so this is just pretty
much like the worst recipe ever yeah
that shouldn't have gone a million
dollar raise got that the Teacher of the
Year yeah witness that she barely got a
raise and then you have the most
aggressive officers hogs this [ __ ]
Jerry Springer right here dead
pretty much god damn here we go an
officer there in the board meetings have
already gone a little way there we have
we work very hard with very little I
just wanna say I don't care that
performance targets were met you're
making our job even more difficult and
we're jumping through hoops and we're
continuously weird you know so we're
needles goes wild
in fact additional leadership is in the
race it's a sad sad day that your
teacher in Vermilion Parish and I feel
like I'm speaking on behalf of more than
just
myself more than just Kaplan teachers
I'm speaking as a group many teachers
are scared since we fell back to one and
all the power missed appeal now has and
it's again I'm going to use the word
absurd that were even considering oh
[Music]
damn that is excessive [ __ ] that is yeah
so now you're gonna get sent to prison
for speaking up about and calmly isn't
that what a board meeting is for I think
I've never been I've never been in a
board meeting but and if I thought
that's what you're supposed to do is
voice your opinions and voice your
whatever you have that you want to talk
about
so who's the little [ __ ] that got so
butthurt that said security can you
please come remove early who the board
president know the superintendent didn't
say anything so a banner count is cash
yeah 148,000 yeah pretty good yeah there
may be were they were they trying to
tell her like okay let us answer but she
kept talking and talking maybe that part
was edited out maybe but even still
like a rest she wasn't like in anyone's
faces like she wasn't speaking so
passionately enough where she's like
spitting she had a fine line of
passionate and she got escorted out but
the arrest part was what that was that
no one caught that on camera like you
could hear the people in the meeting
they're saying like yeah he's putting
her in handcuffs out like what I was
right looked like she was leaving too
cuz he kind of went this way and she
just like walked her own way I thought
yeah she was getting escorted out and
then he was gonna say bye-bye and then
come back the arrest part just makes no
sense yeah that guy is just
trigger-happy maybe she's a power lifter
she actually is really strong one of
these so she was he was trying to push
her down she wouldn't go down was a
little nut check she gave up she should
pulled out a gun out of her purse no one
saw it
damn this is nuts got a [ __ ] stapler
now do that what if she can sue them
through this oh yeah yeah yeah yeah sue
for exactly a hundred forty seven
thousand dollars a year the two board
members they have been claiming that the
board treats women unfairly that they've
they've had a history of kicking women
out for speaking their mind I don't mind
that part it's because women voices are
just a little bit different you know
it's it's Morial it's more annoying so I
can see it's just difficult its whisp
and that kind of tone you know cut that
out
no we need we need to be respected all
right thank you for I didn't speak in a
deeper voice please go TIFF yeah so they
are saying that men who spoke out and
spoken up in the past they have never
been removed so now the ACLU is
commenting on this they're saying that
does she is expulsion from a public
meeting and subsequent arrests are
unacceptable and raise serious
constitutional concerns the constitute
the Constitution prohibits the
government from punishing or retaliating
against people for expressing their
views and the fact that the
schoolteacher was arrested at a public
meeting of the school
is especially troubling it's pretty bad
yeah the board president says that the
officer acted appropriately and he
stands by him 100% is what the Horde
president says yeah yeah well if a
teacher has the authority to send a
student who is acting up and she can't
control out of the classroom
oh the fungus under our policy we have
the same rules yeah they send them out
not to [ __ ] arrest him and check him
on the ground his job is to make sure we
have an orderly meeting he knows what
the law is he knows what our policy is
the officer did exactly what he's
supposed to do and the teachers aren't
kids [ __ ] won't even if they do have
the same right that means you could say
ma'am it's that your time to leave and
that's what you can do if she's acting
unruly that did not look and really at
all yes [ __ ] going crazy yeah you
sent him to a principal's office but if
the kid and not in handcuffs by the way
yeah yeah yeah arrest his own okay
exactly even though I hate to agree with
you well yeah I mean what did they
explain what the rules of conduct was in
those type of meetings maybe it's more
boring and chill and relaxed and no
one's standing up and like you know
emoting at that level if it's a meeting
it's kind of good like what are this
yeah I think you have the right to speak
up and like maybe Joe no because I mean
okay so so the thing is like there's
there might be an agenda to talk about
other things that day and they had a
packed day full of things that they need
to deal with and then she's basically
taking that time to do whatever she
wants to talk about which is still
disrespectful even if what she's saying
is right I think your idea before was
more likely like cuz there was an edit
like what maybe we missed something
maybe she cuz maybe her rant went on for
10 minutes and we only saw 30 seconds
and then she started saying like you a
[ __ ]
and you don't desert them and then and
then it's like alright honey you gotta
go
yeah but the reaction of the people the
crowds was like true but does keep
advice too cuz she's fighting for them
look it was a [ __ ] in the way all yeah
yes and now their threats their death
threats we talked about that we the
internet loves their dead friend yeah
the whole school board is now receiving
death threats teachers and those
administrators know just divorce oh yeah
so then um the offices were even on
temporary lockdown the threats were
being reported the officers and FBI
the superintendent it was silent during
the meeting you [ __ ] knew he didn't
deserve this yeah [ __ ] that guy too
yeah after the fact he released the
statement he this is what he said quote
I hate what happened 20 years of my life
is dedicated to the students of this
community it's so hard to see this
negative it's tough I'm the
superintendent I'm to blame I should
have stood up okay that's what you want
to hear and it's the truth I should have
stood up let her speak within the next
few months we're going to be bringing to
the board a plan where we can bring a
raise for the teachers all right I bring
it back you're not no [ __ ] up real good
job yeah just take whatever money you
just got his daughters are getting [ __ ]
online too but we know we also don't
know how taxing and how difficult that
job is yeah you know that's that's kind
of like the dream where a lot of people
say all rich people are lazy that's why
they have so many services but the gaff
is pretty extreme where his raise is her
salary it is but but but we also know
that government jobs are underpaid sure
there's like 20 years of like the same
rate and then it's like finally this
person gets a job I mean gets the raise
but it's like all [ __ ] you you don't
deserve that because it's just so big I
might have misheard something but did
they say something something parish is
it a private school that turns things
not necessarily excuse for anything but
it does change the system of things yeah
I believe so yeah it might be a private
school which says change something yeah
like the way people are paid yeah yeah
yeah because then it is 100 percent up
to the board like it has nothing to do
with government has nothing to do with
like you said like oh man I got a hustle
10 years and then I'll get my big raise
or whatever or even why the
superintendent's there I feel like you
can put be political make your way to
the top of either private or not but
and private teachers often even though
the school can make money there
self-funding so the teachers aren't
getting paid less which in my opinion in
the private it's more [ __ ] up if this
guy gets paid higher we already know our
government's [ __ ] up but like you said
you already know it's [ __ ] up but in
the private system the whole idea to go
there so you can create your own yeah
form of what you want to see better I
think what will help just is
transparency all around like let people
understand the job description what they
do yeah and then it'll just clear it up
like yeah dude you're you deserve it
you're middle management your job sucks
it's hard yeah it sounded like that
teacher knew though she's like we're
hitting your quota yeah like if she
could have just been an egotistical to
like she seems like a nice lady she
could have been wacko as well but it
seems like you know maybe their thing is
like oh we got to get a B average at the
school and then she's right like it's
the teachers getting to be average not
you sitting in your office that's true
doctor this whole thing went viral the
teacher has released a video of her
response to the arrest and this is what
she said I'm hoping that you choose to
speak out after seeing what happened to
me and you don't let it become an
intimidation to you you let it be your
strength because it's slowly becoming
mine so she's just trying to she's
hoping that people who see this they
won't be intimidated by speaking out so
yeah we'll see where that goes
I hope she sues the [ __ ] up and gets a
[ __ ] ton of money and then she can buy
all the color crayons she wants she buys
the school
[Music]
[Music]
you